[Applause]
america
once again engulfed in anger after
police
opened fire on a black man
a video on social media appears to show
a man trying to get into his car
before he's shot in the back
he's been identified as jacob blake and
was taken to hospital in a serious
condition
his fiancee says his three children were
in the car at the time
you shot him numerous times for no
reason it didn't take all that
disregard that my kids was in the car at
all and you knew they was in there
because i kept screaming it before y'all
even made it to the other side of the
driver's side
to get him in the car i've been yelling
at the whole time
wisconsin's governor has also responded
with a strongly worded statement
saying while we do not have all the
details yet what we know for certain
is that he is not the first black man or
person to have been shot or injured or
mercilessly
killed at the hands of individuals in
law enforcement in our state or country
the kenosha professional police
association
claimed his remarks were wholly
irresponsible
and that the video circulating doesn't
capture all the
intricacies of what took place
but what followed was undoubtedly
outrage
during the unrest one officer appears to
be hit with a brick
what happened oh he just got break
after the shooting the police department
said they had been responding to a
domestic incident
but provided no further details the
officers involved who were yet to be
identified
have been placed on administrative leave
cordelia lynch
sky news